lui c'est charles villa parce qu'on est
depuis plus d'un an et le mois dernier
il m'a proposé de l'accompagner au liban
pour faire une vidéo pour brut avec
médecins du monde pour parler des soins
psychologiques apportée aux réfugiés
syriens
c'est à quoi de votre grand reporter la
vidéo qu'on a fait sur brut parle du
traumatisme qu'ont vécu les familles
syriennes et de ce qui est fait pour les
aider niveau santé mentale au liban je
vous invite à la regarder mais ce n'est
donc pas ce dont je vais parler dans
cette vidéo
charles m'a proposé de faire une vidéo
de mon côté si j'avais une idée d'angle
et ça tombe bien il ya quelques temps je
vous ai parlé dans une vidéo du concept
d'adaptation hédonique en gros je disais
ça peu importe les événements positifs
ou négatifs ou les changements majeurs
dans notre vie on revient assez vite à
un niveau de bonheur stable on pense
qu'on sera plus heureux en ayant une
certaine voiture ou une certaine maison
une fois qu'on l'a on revient vite au
niveau de bonheur initial c'est pour ça
qu'un autre terme c'est les données
cruel 1000 en anglais le tapis roulant
hédonique en fait on pour courir sur la
route du bonheur mais on fait du
surplace
c'est peut-être le moment de savoir si
c'est vrai et si le bonheur qui résulte
de cette adaptation hédonique est réel
et l'un des moyens de le savoir c'est
d'aller à la rencontre de populations
qui ont vécu de vrai traumatisme et leur
demander leur niveau de bonheur
aujourd'hui en philo parfois on se pose
des questions qui ne sont pas belles
équipes ont un peu honte et qui ne sont
pas vraiment politiquement correct
j'avais donc une de ces questions
concernant les réfugiés syriens sont ils
heureux
[Musique]
je savais qu'avec charles et médecins du
monde on allait avoir plusieurs
interviews alors je me suis dit que
j'allais poser la même question à tout
le monde
selon vous sur une échelle de 0 à 10 à
quel point êtes-vous heureux
dans la vidéo brut vous verrez qu'on
commence par le camp plus combat
l'hôpital mais chronologiquement on a
fait l'inversé
et voici ma toute première interview
charles lance le rec
ce qui fait que vous êtes ici et
l'interprète traduit ma question j'ai
avec mes petites questions
philosophiques à deux balles et en 40
secondes je me prends la violence de la
vie en pleine gueule cette femme elle
s'appelle nisrine elle a fui idleb en
syrie il ya six ans quand sa maison a
été bombardée
elle a perdu sa mère elle a perdu son
frère
les deux dans des conditions horribles
à 33 ans elle a quatre enfants et un
mari il n'y a que 20 % des réfugiés
syriens qui vivent dans des camps mais
la plupart vivent dans des squats ou des
parkings
eux ils vivent dans un coin de
supermarchés les enfants se font
maltraiter par certains heureuse où
seront frappés à l'école par d'autres
camarades s'ils voulaient rentrer en
syrie
leur maison est aujourd'hui détruite ils
n'ont plus de chez eux
heureusement ils peuvent venir ici
bénéficier de thérapies dont ils ont
besoin notamment les enfants et nisrine
en est très contente c'est une interview
difficile à me raconter son histoire
elle s'est confiée à moi donc avec brut
on vous en parle et qu'on sensibilise
les gens sur ce qu'il se passe là bas il
reste la réponse à ma question
j'avoue que j'ai visités à la poser mais
bon il faut que j'aille au bout de mon
idée
5 sérieusement après avoir vécu tout ça
comment c'est possible
il s'est posé la question
[Musique]
ça marche pas trop avant de partir je
pose la question à la psychologue
à l'issue des discussions
atteignant presque
[Musique]
audi ondées
oh
non
nous voici dans le camp de sanayeh comme
je disais 20% des réfugiés syriens sont
dans des camps de ce type
pour vous donner une idée du nombre de
réfugiés au liban une personne sur
quatre est réfugié c'est énorme
les gens qui vivent ici sont là depuis
plusieurs années maintenant dans des
conditions très difficiles sous des
bâches à même le sol inondé dès qu'il
pleut un peu trop ils sont parfois là
depuis plus de six ans ils vont à
l'école ils travaillent ils vivent
d'ailleurs la voiture avec des ballons
que vous voyez derrière moi c'est parce
qu'il fêtait un mariage quand on y est
on leur pose des questions sur
fonctionnement du camp et je rajoute les
miennes nous la découvrons maintenant
[Musique]
c'était découvrir sa loi et elle est la
seule à même de la chasse à le surmonter
on a donc cette capacité à se créer du
bonheur à le synthétiser c'est
d'ailleurs sûrement étroitement liées à
l'adaptation et de nick dont vous parlez
c'est assez fou mais avant de rentrer
j'aimerais bien aller voir des gens qui
ont tout pour être heureux des gens qui
sont dans un des états les plus riches
du monde des gens qui ont toujours le
soleil des gens qui sont libres je
quitte charles et je m'envole des
actions la californie à los angeles
[Musique]
entre vous et moi je suis surtout aller
pour assister à la remise de diplôme de
master et d'ailleurs je t'embrasse très
fort je te félicite encore
[Musique]
ouais
ça va
c'est dur d'en tirer quelque chose même
si je trouve ça toujours intéressant
d'écouter les gens parler mais je me
demande si le bonheur de gens qui ont
tout ce qu'ils veulent ou presque comme
potentiellement un californien à la même
force qu'un bonheur qu'on se donne quand
on m'a pas ce couple
comme les réfugiés dans le camp nou il
ya deux choses dont je me suis rendu
compte en partant en mission avec
charles déjà notre action est très
limité on fait ce qu'on peut
non on ne peut pas faire des miracles et
heureusement il ya des gens je pense
notamment à médecins du monde qui font
sur place ce travail formidable
l'autre truc dont je me suis rendu
compte c'est qu'en fait ce n'est pas
qu'une question de bonheur parce que si
ce n'était qu'une question de bonheur
ces populations n'aurait peut-être pas
besoin d'être car on l'a vu c'est très
difficile à dire et à admettre mais
parfois
elles ne sont pas beaucoup moins
malheureuse
[Musique]
évidemment le but avec cette vidéo
n'était pas de faire une expérience
rigoureuse mais plutôt d'illustrer par
le témoignage un concept psychologique
est à mon sens philosophique mais donc
on l'a vu ce n'est pas qu'une question
de bonheur quand on voit des familles
qui vivent six ans sous des bâches
ce n'est pas une question de bonne heure
c'est une question de dignité on voit
une femme qui se bat pour le bien-être
de ses enfants alors qu'elle a tout
perdu
ce n'est pas une question bonheur une
question de justice cette dignité
cette justice c'est ce qui fait notre
humanité ce n'est pas pour les rendre
heureux
mais c'est pour leur rendre ce que le
monde leur a pris évidemment le bonheur
est important mais ce n'est pas la seule
valeur john stuart mill en parle bien
quand elle dit qu'il vaut mieux être un
homme insatisfaits qu'un port satisfaits
ou qu'il vaut mieux être socrates
insatisfaits qu'un imbécile satisfait la
satisfaction est donc le bonheur ne sont
donc peut-être pas au dessus de tout
alors merci à charles et à médecins du
monde qui m'ont permis de vous parler un
peu de ces populations à aller voir la
vidéo qu'on a fait avec charles sur la
chaîne de brut explique plus en détail
la situation
encore une fois ce n'était pas le but de
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas aussi à
envisager de me soutenir sur tipi ce
genre de vidéos me coûte énormément en
temps c'est un plaisir à faire et je ne
veux pas les sponsorisés et pour que je
puisse continuer à en faire
j'ai besoin d'un coup de pouce de votre
part ce sera aussi une manière de me
dire que vous en voulez plus allez
également voir la chaîne de charles qui
a fait plusieurs docu sur des zones de
conflit en plus d'être une belle
personne
love peace et à bientôt moi je mettrais
la note de 7
c'était autour de 8 c'est notre réel
niveau de bonheur environ 1,7
parce que je suis confiant en train
d'acquérir de ma dépression note sur 10
choc
je pense que je me mettrais un bond à 8
sur 10 quelques jours entre 5 et 6 mai
mais j'ai mis en chantier des trucs qui
pourrait convertir ici quelques danses
sous 6 078 jeu mais neuf et demi parce
que 10 c'est trop a fait demi ça permet
d'avoir un peu d'espoir sur le fait que
la tenir ça sera encore meilleure et les
amoureux forcément je vais pas un 9.10
mais je pense que je serai plus heureuse
quand cela plus puis je grandis plantes
qu'il ya plein de période de ma vie où
je me sentais très très triste et j'ai
juste l'impression que rien n'allait et
maintenant que je regarde mais elle m'a
si en fait il ya énormément de choses en
famille qui allait de la bâche durée
mais le fait est que mercy que ça peut
changer à tout instant alors
j'attribuerai la note de 7 sur 10 à mon
bonheur puisque d'un côté je suis très
entourée très heureux j'ai eu beaucoup
de chance dans la vie dans le temps j'en
vois beaucoup à l'idée de ne pas
accomplir les choses que j'ai envie
d'accomplir
9 on peut tous s'estiment heureux je
pense de vivre en europe d'avoir à
manger tous les jours et c'est la vie
c'est du kif en fait